[Musique]
un petit peu moins de cinq mois avant
l'élection présidentielle tous les
candidats ne sont pas encore déclarés on
l'a encore vu avec et l'eczéma ou reims
et déclaration n'est jamais anodine tant
sur le fond que sur la forme on parle
d'ailleurs souvent d'acte fondateur et
qui mieux que jacques séguéla
publicitaire pour nous parler de ces
moments historiques non non non non je
je le pense vraiment vous avez
accompagné françois mitterrand et
d'autres dans leur campagne électorale
c'est important de réussir son entrée en
scène sa candidature tout est important
dans une campagne et et surtout le
démarrage à l'époque c'était très
important parce que la télévision dictée
tout aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux ont
remis le télévision à sa place et donc
ça n'a pas l'importance que ça eu pour
un 1.2 goal pour un giscard pour un
amical le dernier en date c'est eric
zemmour mardi qui dans une vidéo sur
youtube a déclaré sa candidature il a
repris justement les codes du général de
gaulle en parlant assis à un bureau
devant son micro en lisant son texte
vous en avez pensé quoi de cette
déclaration j'en ai pensé du mal et du
bien du mal parce que c'est quand même
conquis néolait sq de faire un bras
d'honneur aux français et trois jours
après de se déguiser en temps de gaulle
est à la fois du bien parce que une fois
de plus il a fait le buzz une fois de
plus on parle que de lui une fois de
plus ce sont les journalistes qui
devrait quand même essayer de mieux
faire leur métier ce fonds se font avoir
et une fois de plus si t il à la vedette
donc le communicant le bravo le
politique fait gaffe tu veux pas dire
n'importe quoi tu ne peux pas faire
n'importe quoi à mon vieux le français
ont été testés alors on va essayer de ne
pas parler que de lui dans l'inattendu
camille vous avez sélectionné quelques
déclarations de candidatures oui alors
je vous rassure on va pas regarder
toutes les déclarations de candidatures
de la cinquième des produits ouais on a
essayé de prendre celles qui ont un
petit peu le plus imprégné l'histoire du
pays d'abord donc toutes les
personnalités s'en revendiquent laure et
le général de gaulle en
1965 il est président sortant il se
représente aux potes et surtout c'est là
hier fois qu'un président va être élu au
suffrage universel direct en france il
se présente au journal de 20 heures
depuis l'elysée nous sommes le 4
novembre 65 1 mois et 1 jour avant le
premier tour une allocution de 9 minutes
30 que les français vous voyez vous
regarder de manière très sérieuse depuis
des cafés dont la rue dont voici un
extrait aujourd'hui
je crois devoir
me tenir prêt à poursuivre ma tâche
mesurant en connaissance de cause
de quels efforts il s'agit
mais convaincu qu actuellement
c'est le mieux pour servir la france que
l'adhésion franche et massive des
citoyens
m'engage à rester en fonction
l'avenir de la république nouvelle sera
décidément assuré sinon
personne ne peut douter
qu'elle s'écroulera aussitôt alors cette
déclaration c'est moi ou le chaos
finalement il ya que lui qui pouvait la
faire d'abord il faut bien comprendre
une chose la télévision c'est 50% le
carré de la télévision un coup en avant
c'est agressif en cours en arrière c'est
répressif
20%
c'est la gestuelle
et le dit ce n'est plus que 15% et c'est
simplement parce que le lendemain les
journalistes ont le reprendre et c'est
beaucoup de que ledit va refaire surface
mais il ya quand même un petit comme
avec le côté je sais bien sûr qu'à douze
mois qui peut sauver le pays bien sûr ça
c'est le fond il ya la forme et le fond
alors ça c'était la forme donc et
d'ailleurs il est impérial
les temples c'est un empereur bon
et puis dans le fond il n'est pas par
quatre chemins le permettra il a gagné
la guerre alors jacques séguéla vous
avez été sollicité à la fois par par les
équipes u jacques chirac françois
mitterrand valéry giscard d'estaing
valéry giscard d'estaing qui qui a tenté
d'être proche des français camilla pour
pour annoncer ces candidatures oui en
1974 il est ministre de pompidou il se
présente depuis chamalières son fief
dans la mairie donc du puy-de-dôme et il
veut comme il dit je reprends ses mots
regarder la france au fond des yeux est
ce que c'est malin jacques séguéla de se
présenter en province oui parce que
c'est la promesse qui décide c'est pas
varié même si elle est plus au parisien
alors en tout cas en 80 il se présente
un second mandat mais cette fois il se
présente depuis paris oui depuis paris
et puis surtout regardez vous allez voir
son dorure sur fond neutre est si j'ose
dire avec pour seul décor un bouquet de
fleurs et sa femme j'ai décidé de me
présenter à l'élection présidentielle
pour un septennat nouveau
pendant sept ans
mon devoir d'état
et la réserve nécessaire à ma fonction
monte interdit de s'exprimer en toute
liberté
enfin je vais pouvoir vous dire d'homme
à homme ce que j'ai dans l'esprit et sur
le coeur je ne serai pas un président
candidat mais un citoyen candidat on l'a
entendu un s'exprimer librement le
regard franc dire ce qu'il a dans
l'esprit et sur le coeur valéry giscard
d'estaing manier très bien les ficelles
de la communication politique trop bien
pourquoi il faut oui parce qu'à la
première fois il était naturel la
première fois on s'est reconcentré qui
joue sa vie et la deuxième fois que j'ai
tellement l'impression que c'est même
pas la main qui se présente ça va
continuer il fait toutes les fautes
d'abord
sa femme
les français
élisent un couple ils ne veulent pas
voir la femme dans le couple qui mais à
l'époque c'était ça faut pas l'oublier
et deuxièmement il était à la mode il a
créé la mode dans sa première
candidature et tout d'un coup il
apparaît démodé il apparaît démodé et
les démos des à l'image même aujourd'hui
on voit bien que la première déclaration
est plus épais plus dans le goût du jour
que ne l'est la seconde une déclaration
d'intention aux français ça doit se
faire avec le coeur et là c'est fait
avec la tête vous allez voir mitterrand
allait voir mi temps vous allez voir la
différence va les voir là où la tuer
alors justement j'allais vous dire votre
nom est indissociable de celui de
françois mitterrand déjà ce qui fait la
force tranquille de 81 c'est vous alors
là quand tu as quand j'ai présenté le
slogan je n'ai jamais écrit sur un
papier julie président fermer les yeux
ouvrez les yeux j'ai vu qu'il plongeait
comme ça dans le taxi m'a dit
séguéla vous m'avez trouvé est un
mastodonte qui réussissent elles selon
qui trouve son héros alors génération
mitterrand en 81 8 c'est aussi vous vous
lavez refait le coup du papier ou pas
donc génération mi temps c'était
impossible parce que mes bons mots de
juillet me dis je vais pas me présenter
son cancer fait beaucoup souffrir c'est
rocard kebbal faire mais je voudrais que
ce soit vous qui face à la campagne de
rocard et me raccompagne et sur le
chemin elysia il me dit mais on sait
jamais peut-être que rocard peut refuser
peut-être qu'il aurait vu quelque chose
donc il faut que la fiche que vous allez
faire servat rocard me servent aussi ce
président pas faire une fugue de yaourt
une voiture il faut choisir c'est que là
vous avez des idées d'où la première
affiche politique où on ne voit pas le
politicien et donc il fallait le
remplacer par quelque chose il est
remplacé par ma petite il avait un an
avec le slogan génération mitterrand qui
servait hardcore comme tu me semblait
aussi bien un mitterrand jacques en tout
cas cette cette campagne a marqué
pourtant et vous venez nous l'expliqué
pourquoi camille il a mis du temps à se
déclarer bah oui il a attendu le dernier
moment écoutez cet extrait du journal de
13 heures d'antenne 2 on né le 4 mars
1988 le premier tour et le 24 avril et
françois mitterrand ne veut toujours pas
dire s'il est oui ou non candidat je
suis pas candidat je veux garder mon
autorité le plus longtemps possible
notamment sur la scène internationale je
le suis on pourra quand même quatre mois
al avance trois mois d'avant
peu à peu c'est pourquoi cette nouvelle
que vous désirez connaître vous
n'attendrez pas très longtemps avant de
la prendre alors ça c'est très habile
parce que c'est lui qui a inventé ce
qu'il a d'ailleurs lui-même qualifié la
stratégie du désir le teasing et que
jusqu'au bout il a dit givati gvt acquis
pas et justement 18 jours après
l'extrait convient de voir le 22 mars un
mois et un jour avant le premier tour je
serai le dernier journaliste de france
et de navarre à vous poser cette
question que le président êtes-vous à
nouveau candidat à la présidence de la
république
oui le oui du jeune fille énergie le oui
pure et cristalline merveille à vous
avez mûrement réfléchie je le crois
qu'on peut savoir quand vous avez pris
cette décision certains 17 en juillet 87
d'autres disent et pendant les fêtes de
fin d'année je n'en sais rien moi même
il était préparé ce we ou pas non non il
n'est pas préparé par les publicitaires
qu'a donc c'est pas mes joues ton km il
paraît les juno moi je voulais lui
parler après et je suis assez curieux
vous êtes vous avez l'air un peu
embarrassés
un peu tendu il dit mais finalement j'ai
tout oublié j'ai dit oui alors
inversement il ya un candidat camille
qui lui n'attendez pas le dernier moment
oui et c'est jacques chirac on peut le
dire lui il avait coutume de se
présenter à ses taux ce n'était pas son
genre d'entrer dans l'arène politique un
mois avant le premier tour et puis aussi
sur la forme il a tout tenté 1981 il se
présente à la présidentielle par un
communiqué de presse 15 lignes rendue
publique de l'eau depuis l'hôtel de
ville de paris en 81 8 vous le voyez
c'est une candidature depuis son bureau
à matignon 94 ils changent c'est par
voie de presse par la presse régionale
la voix du nord et il était lui en 95 et
enfin en 2002 il se présente de manière
faussement imprévus en février deux mois
et demi avant le premier tour dans une
gare à avignon depuis quelques jours
je ne peux pas faire un pas hors de chez
moi ou de mammeri sans qu'on me pose de
la question et je crois que cette
question on se la pose partout en france
le président va t-il déclaré sa
candidature
alors chère marie josée rouag
je vous le dis vous m'avez posé une
question directe et franche et bien j'y
répondrai dans le même esprit oui je
suis candidat
alors c'est une opération comme
formidable en bulgare des justes jacques
séguéla ces images de son retour à paris
cette meute de journalistes qu'il attend
sur le quai du train vous m'avez dit en
préparant cette émission que c'était la
meilleure candidature à la
présidentielle pourquoi parce que c'est
sa fille qui l'a fait élire sans sa
fille et sa femme chirac n'aurait pas
été élu c'est elle qui a décidé de
prendre la campagne en main qui a écarté
tous les publicitaires autour de lui et
qu'à régler chaque image une dernière
déclaration à vous montrer jacques
séguéla c'est celle du président actuel
emmanuel macron cette fois on est en
2016 quand il se présente il est ancien
ministre de l'économie il se présente
cinq mois avant le premier tour dans un
centre de formation en seine-saint-denis
il a rédigé sa déclaration dans la nuit
ce matin le ton est solennel
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république
parce que je crois plus que tout que
nous pouvons réussir lui il devait
parler le plus tôt possible parce qu'il
fallait que les médias l'accompagnent en
tant que président est arrivé de nulle
part personne ne le connaissait il avait
été ministre mais en coup de vent donc
il fallait absolument qu'il ait le temps
d'affirmer de mettre son costume de
président qui d'ailleurs va se révéler
le au louvre le jour de son élection
donc c'est une petite une gradation qui
a été très bien fait mais sans
publicitaire
busser c'était lui donc ça c'est très
malin
mais peut-être qui va quand même trouvé
une autre façon de nous surprendre parce
que la surprise fait partie de la
campagne présidentielle il ya quelques
semaines vous avez été surpris jacques
séguéla en train de glisser justement à
l'oreille du président des mots comme
quoi vous aviez un slogan pour lui
pensez à quoi c'est vous qui le sait a
dit le new la bonne idée du fauvisme non
non ça veut dire qu'il va le reprendre
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas ça à
stocker et vanter c'est plus un sonneur
mais le suspect s'est créé merci jacques
séguéla pour pour cet éclairage est
votre vision de des campagnes
présidentielles ça ne me rajeunit pas je
préviens mais c'est passionnant et vous
reviendrez avec grand plaisir